ja es geht auch um das Thema CDU in dem
Fall es geht um die Bundeskanzlerin um
die scheidende Bundeskanzlerin die ja
quasi in bassda Mentalität noch mal ein
Thema abgeräumt hat dass das Land hier
über Jahre und noch immer noch bewegt
das Thema ist die flüchtlingskrise von
2015 damals hat Angela Merkel einen
bemerkenswerten Satz gesagt sie hat
gesagt wir schaffen das hat das ein
Bundesbürgern zugerufen hat dafür
massive Kritik einstecken müssen und
jetzt hat Angela Merkel in einem
Interview gesagt als Rückblende quasi
als Rückblick auf das nach sechs Jahren
ja wir haben das geschafft Angela Merkel
schließt einfach dieses Kapitel
flüchtlingskrise für sich in
bassamentalität und sagt es hat alles
wunderbar geklappt aber wenn man auf die
Zahlen schaut dann muss man doch
feststellen so einfach Frau
Bundeskanzlerin geht das nicht denn wir
wissen beispielsweise dass gerade bei
den Frauen also bei denen die zu uns
gekommen sind vor fünf Jahren nicht mal
ein Drittel dieser Frauen dieser
weiblichen Flüchtlinge einen Job haben
also sprich ein Ausbildungsplatz ein
Minijob oder ein ganz regulären Job bei
den Männern sind es nicht mal zwei
Drittel wir wissen aber beispielsweise
dass auch zwei Drittel der Syrer derzeit
von Hartz IV leben zwei Drittel der
Syrer die in Deutschland sind und beim
Thema Kriminalität lohnt auch ein Blick
in die Statistik die ist nämlich
deutlich gestiegen was die ausländischen
Tatverdächtigen angeht deutlich
gestiegen seit 2015 Antworten es ist
viel zu früh hier schon ein
Schlussstrich zu ziehen eine Bilanz zu
ziehen und sicherlich ist es völlig
falsch zu sagen ja wir haben das
geschafft denn wir sind noch mittendrin
und komplett können wir überhaupt nicht
sagen ob wir das geschafft haben
Jan ich bin da zweigeteilter Meinung zum
einen bin ich ja vor allem wegen der
flüchtlingskrise ein Fan von Angela
Merkel nicht so wie das Landes umgesetzt
hat aber es war ein historischer
humanitärischer Akt und ich war froh in
der Zeit Deutsch zu sein ich war stolz
darauf dass Frau Merkel ist gemacht hat
und ich frage mich immer was wäre denn
die andere Lösung gewesen dass wir also
an der Grenze dann da entschieden hätten
das Kind kommt noch rein die Frau kommt
noch rein also da wäre jetzt meine Frage
an dich was wäre für dich eine
praktikable Lösung gewesen und das
zweite ist ich finde es immer so
schwierig dass wir über dieses
Flüchtlingsproblem sprechen ich finde
wir haben eine Integrationsproblem und
da müssen wir natürlich ganz schnell
Boris Palma bei den letzten zu Gast bei
8:15 Uhr er hat gefordert lasst die
Flüchtlinge nicht arbeitslos sein weil
die Wahrheit ist nämlich nicht dass alle
Flüchtlinge super voll zu Hause sind und
ich arbeiten wollen die Wahrheit ist ich
habe 2018 auch im Flüchtlingsheim
gearbeitet die Wahrheit ist dass viele
zurückgehalten werden weil sie kriegen
keine Arbeitserlaubnis und in diesen
Heimen werden sie zusammengefärbt so
kann Integration nicht glücken deswegen
wäre meine Aufforderung lasst uns
endlich mit der guten Integration
beginnen aber ich finde immer Frau
Merkel wir schaffen das nicht ich finde
das führt immer eher dazu dass die
Gesellschaft noch mehr gegen die
Flüchtlinge ist und die Integration eh
niemals machen wird als these um mal
drüber nachzudenken was eigentlich
dahinter steckt ist das schon richtig
man braucht eine These um sich mit dem
Thema zu beschäftigen und für eine
Bestandsaufnahme aus Merkel Sicht oder
aus unserer aller Sicht ist dieser Satz
einfach zu wenig da stimme ich ihm zu
ich war auch für die Flüchtlingspolitik
von merkmin ist immer noch altes für
richtig als die vor der Grenze standen
Budapest kam was sollte man da machen
bin ich nach wie vor der Meinung aber
wir können erstens hat sie es über die
Jahre abgelehnt ein
Integrationsministerium einzurichten
wenn man selbst dass man mit Helmut Kohl
vergleicht der bei den bei den ersten
aufkommenden Atomunfall in Tschernobyl
etc ein ein Umweltministerium
eingerichtet hat auf Bundesebene und für
reaktorschutz der hat sofort reagiert
Merkel hat auf das Problem gar nicht
reagiert hat es den verschiedenen
Instanzen überlassen und fand ich immer
zu wenig statt einer aktive
Integrationspolitik zu betreiben
zweitens gehört zu einer Bilanz dazu das
was wir heute aus Weißrussland erleben
als organisierte sehen wir ja gerade
heute Flüchtlingszug zur polnischen
Grenze begleitet vom weißrussischen
Militär da wird das nachgestellt was wir
damals über den Balkan erlebt haben und
das kann man inzwischen wissen das ist
nämlich ein Teil der Wahrheit auch Herr
Erdogan in der Türkei hat Busse zur
Küste fahren lassen voller Flüchtlinge
um sie dort aber auch er war ein
Schlepper um Druck auf die Europäische
Union auszuüben weil sie ihn nicht
aufgenommen haben und ständig
Schwierigkeiten waren er hat die
Flüchtlinge auf Boote setzen lassen und
in die Türkei in die nach Griechenland
übersetzen lassen das ist die Blaupause
für das gewesen was Lukaschenka heute in
Weißrussland macht muss man einfach
selbstkritisch zur Kenntnisse
in Budapest was hätte man machen sollen
ja also wenn man es jetzt über spitz
formuliert man kann es auch so machen
wie die polnische Regierung nicht nur
die Belarus Regierung sondern Polen als
unser Nachbarland ich bin auch mit dem
Polen verheiratet so geht es natürlich
auch ob das in unserem moralischen Sinne
ist oder in unserem wir tun jetzt ja
gerade so als wenn es nur um diesen
Budapester Bahnhof gingen gehen würde
das ist ja eigentlich nicht der Fall
sondern der Budapester Bahnhof genau das
war der Anfang und dann sahen wir über
Wochen ja über Monate
Flüchtlingszüge nach Deutschland kommen
und eine Bundeskanzlerin die sich sogar
noch dagegen gewehrt hat Grenzen zu
schließen und den österreichischen
Bundeskanzler dafür kritisiert hat dass
er es gemacht hat die hat nämlich am
Ende die Balkanroute geschlossen von der
sie mit ihrer Politik aber dann
profitiert hat weil dann der
Flüchtlingsstrom nämlich abgeschnitten
oder beendet wurde also sie profitierte
davon im Land hat aber den Bundeskanzler
gescheut und deswegen noch einmal ganz
konkret die Frage was hätte ich gemacht
im Land gibt der Punkt ist ja ein
anderer also wir haben darüber
gesprochen beispielsweise einfach dass
die Aufgaben so groß sind wie zuletzt
bei der deutschen Bewältigung der
deutschen Einheit da sind wir jetzt im
Jahr 30 oder 31 und sprechen immer noch
darüber was es noch an Problem gibt wie
kann ich jetzt nach sechs Jahren bereits
einen Schlussstrich ziehen und sagen ja
hat alles wunderbar geklappt wir haben
das geschafft das ist einfach eine
Anmaßung und das kann diese
Bundeskanzlerin nicht tun also
Integrationsarbeit ist sicherlich ein
langfristiges Projekt aber das jetzt mit
der deutschen Einheit zu vergleichen ist
doch ein Stückchen weit hergeholt
letztendlich gehören zur Integration
immer beide Seiten ja sowohl wir als
gastgebendes Land aber natürlich auch
die Menschen die zu uns kommen ich kann
aus Politiker Sicht schon sagen dass wir
unglaublich viel unternommen haben um
zunächst einmal die gesetzlichen
Grundlagen für eine gute und aktive
Integrationsarbeit zu leisten was ich
aber feststelle ist dass der politische
Wille in diesem Land
Integration nicht nur zu ermöglichen
sondern auch einzufordern und im Zweifel
auch mit Konsequenzen zu belegen nicht
vorhanden ist ja also wir haben immer
noch Bundesländer nicht in dem Maße die
Rückführungen durchführen wie sie es
könnten und wie sie es müssten also wir
haben wirklich auch Schlupflöcher an
vielen Stellen wir haben auch einen
Rechtssystem das natürlich vielen
Migranten die Möglichkeit gibt dauerhaft
auch den ihr Bleiberecht zu erwirken und
das sind alles ein Stück weit auch
rechtslücken und Fehler auch im System
die wir auch beheben müssen und man darf
noch eines hinzufügen die Entscheidungen
von 2015 kann man so oder so sehen aber
am Ende hat das auch zu einer Spaltung
unserer Gesellschaft geführt wir
diskutieren heute noch an den
Mittagstischen bei der Oma bei dem Opa
über dieses Thema was werden die
Alternative gewesen weil es wird immer
darüber debattiert
Alternative die Alternative ist doch
ganz klar also ich habe Budapest gehabt
und habe auch gesehen was das für eine
Sogwirkung
ausgestrahlt hat und es haben uns noch
andere Länder vorgemacht österreich hat
doch dann am Ende ein ganz klaren Kurs
umgesetzt hat doch gesagt wir lassen
niemanden mehr ins Land und hat die
Grenzen zugemacht aber das doch genau
der Punkt wenn ich nicht mal weiß
in meinen Land kommen wenn ich die
Kontrolle das haben die
Sicherheitsbehörden ja auch bestätigt
wenn ich die Kontrolle darüber verliere
und nicht mehr weiß wen ich mir ins Land
hole und sage ich kann die Grenzen
können was ist denn oder gibt es für sie
einen Zeitpunkt oder woran machen die
fest wenn Integrationspolitik gelungen
ist wenn der erste Syrer der deutsche
Frau her reitet und zwei blonde Kinder
bekommt oder was ist für Sie
ausschlaggeben wenn die wenn die
Statistiken besser werden wenn der
hartz-iv-anteil runter geht wonach
machen Sie eine gelungene Integration
Zahlen die ich gerade genannt habe eins
ist auch klar da waren glaube ich ganz
ganz viele auch Firmenchefs in der Zeit
ja komplett verblendet die erdachten es
kommen nur top ausgebildete Manager und
Zahnärzte in dieses Land also es gab
viele Vorstandsvorsitzende
beispielsweise den von Daimler der
gejubelt hat und gesagt alles wunderbar
und wenn man das jetzt mit den Zahlen
vergleicht die wir sehen dann ist
möglicherweise der ein oder andere
geblendet gewesen von einer Euphorie die
im Land herrscht geherrscht hat mache
ich gar keinen Vorwurf aber am Ende geht
es schon darum dass ein Land wie
Deutschland mit einem sehr sehr gut
ausgebauten Sozialsystem das ist ja nun
mal so schon ein bisschen die Kontrolle
behält darüber wer eigentlich zu uns
kommt und wer nicht und damit meine ich
gar nicht dass hier das Asylrecht
ausgehebelt werden soll aber das was
Frau schiffke gerade sagte dass
Asylrecht muss konsequent angewendet
werden wer hier kein Bleiberecht hat der
muss auch wieder gehen Wanderung es darf
nicht vermischt werden mit
fachkräftezuwanderung das ist ein ganz
ganz wichtig den Mut haben zu sagen wer
zu uns kommen darf und wer hier arbeiten
soll
Asylrecht kann es nicht geben und was
hätte man tun können die Ampel übrigens
weil sie gerade die Ampel so gelobt
haben was denn ja die möchten genau Dich
habe
bin ich noch ja wird sich wahrscheinlich
ändern aber ich sag's mal so man hätte
zu diesem Zeitpunkt nichts anders machen
können die Europäische Union ist ja dann
unter der Hand anders verfahren also die
Griechen gehen ja schon lange das sind
ja schon lange dazu übergegangen bootet
diese auf dem Mittelmeer aus aufbringen
zurückzuschicken die Türkei das ist nach
europäischen Recht unzulässig weil
Asylanträge gar nicht gestellt werden
können weil die Menschen gar keine
Chance haben zu begründen warum sie
darüber wollen